all right um
shall we start uh I guess down
yeah I think we're starting all right
perfect uh okay so welcome all to the
second part of the morning session uh we
have two talks uh 45 minutes each uh one
on qbf and and one on Isom isomorphic
generation uh of combinatory objects
with such modulo and symmetries
a very nice being here connecting with
everyone
yeah so
um
I'm talking about the generation of
combinatorial objects use things up and
so this is something that
um in in combinatorics often especially
raised in this way uh is there a graph
or some other combinatorial object with
a certain property does it exists or not
um and um yeah what combinatorial
objects are there graphs hypergraphs
Matrix Etc everything that I I'm
considering things that are like finite
structures during a talk I will mainly
focus on graphs but uh later on with the
applications I will also have a few
things about uh other objects
and there are variants of it we want for
instance to enumerate all objects of a
certain size with our property X
um extremely properties extremely
problems in extremely combinatorics
people are for instance
for example interested uh the largest
number of edges can graph with n
vertices have so where the graph is a
certain property this there are books on
extremely communatorics but also counter
examples for conjectures that we can at
least show that the conjecture holds up
to a certain uh size of objects or maybe
ultimately show the conjecture in
general because sometimes we know that
from a certain size onwards the
conjecture is true whether some
theoretical proofs but the the small
examples they basically often contain
this really difficulty where this more
General asymptotic
reasoning is not drastic
okay but now this isomorph free
Generation
Um so the number of objects of course
explodes very quickly so the number of
graphs uh with the standard vertices I
think it's already like a billion
um and so to at least
um keep this explosion to some it's
still exploding but let's say it
explodes a little bit slower is uh by
means of canonization because every
object you have many isomorphic objects
that basically you only need to have
among all these isomorphic copies you
only need to consider one of them and
one way is to to a canonization is a
mapping Alpha that maps to every object
um like a unique element of its
isomorphism class and we only want to
generate objects that are canonical so
that map to themselves
for instance here we have two two graphs
um but they are basically isomorphic by
this this uh um mapping is isomorphism
here we only need to have one of them
and there are many ways of canonization
and
um a popular one and the very natural
one is by you you look at the adjacency
Matrix of the graph so you have vertices
times vertices and the zero if the edge
is missing a one if the edge is there
and um then you associate with this
adjacency Matrix a long string where
you're just concatenate all its rows and
if you now order these objects by
lexicographically along their adjacency
Matrix you have a total ordering and
here for instance you can see the left
one is smaller than the right one
therefore in the ordering we want we can
exclude the right one
um and um
yeah
um
and now for but for connected graphs
here to just see the common door
explosion this is without considering
um this this isomorph regeneration and
um here you see
um we get it's it's growing slower so
for 10 vertices here this is uh already
crazy you can't check something one
after one uh here that's still kind of
viewable maybe even one million then it
also here it starts getting uh getting
difficult
um and there is like a a very standard
tool people in combinatorics use called
nautique uh introduced by Brandon McKay
more than 20 years ago uh where you can
uh generate objects like graphs
um modular isomorphism and
um so you'll find that you can list all
connected graphs with 10 vertices it
gives you this this million of graphs
and you there's also that you can use
some
restrictions we only want to have cubic
graphs for instance where the every
vertex has a certain degree then you can
incorporate this into this generation
then it maybe goes for a little few more
vertices higher but it's still if your
your property are looking for it's a
little bit more advanced then you can't
build it into a naughty and then you
need to do a generate and test method so
you're generating all these canonical
graphs and vertices and then you test
your property that you're looking for
and then you get the result
but of course then if if the number just
of this object is too large then then
you can't do this
is therefore
um there exists a start approach we can
do this we start and we can can kind of
avoid uh this generating test
yeah either is we
um combine the generate anti-test in one
process
um we can express our property
um in a propositional formula where for
instance a graph is very natural for
every edge of this graph that we don't
have already it's a like this this graph
we are looking for but we have um
variables for every Edge and whether
there is an edge between vertex I and
vertex J this variable e i j is true or
not
and so by uh expressing now our property
in propositional logic we can now look
uh whether the formula is satisfiable
and if it's satisfiable we have our
object that we are looking for and now
um we we can we can also use auxiliary
verbs to maybe this property we can't
Define just on this Edge level but
um so we have two sorts of variables now
the idea is this we still have our our
we have now our formula FX which says
there exists the graph on N vertices
with our property
and the graph is minimal with respect to
let's say the lexicographical ordering
and then we feed this into a set solver
and then we get our site so this would
be perfect if it works like this
however there is a caveat because
um it's not known it's complete
minimality check to express this with a
polynomial number of clauses
so there there is um people have tried
uh the following which works not too bad
to have epilex notion of minimality for
instance uh this year would say that
when we swap any two uh vertices in with
a permutation it only swaps two vertices
we shouldn't get lexicographically
smaller graph
yes we can express with with uh um
relatively small number of Clauses and
it would at least filter out some of the
isomorphic copies but of course uh for a
general automotism it could swap
basically around all the end vertices so
it's only helping a little bit so this
works for for instance I'll use this
um with some good results but still only
a small fraction of isomorphic obviously
feel good now the question is can we
still use that and but do better and
filter more
and um
therefore this was the static static
approach because we have a static
um encoding of this minimality but now
this would be a dynamic approach so here
again we have propositional formula that
expresses our property but just this
formula that's the only input to the sub
solver
but now we use a propagator so whenever
the subserver finds a model or maybe
earlier when it already has decided of
some of the relevant variable it asks a
external tool that looks rather this is
canonical or not and if not a clause is
learned and feedback into our cdcl I
don't I omit cdcl we I'm here always
talking about cdcl sub solvers and only
then when the solver finally comes to a
solution then it's canonical
and
actually many people have already used
this in some way or the other maybe two
uh systems cdcl Sim or sat plus computer
assistant
um no computer algebra system computer
algebra system thank you
um or maybe two uh
um famous uh tools that have been
developed uh in recent years
um and
here I'm not talking about our version
of it SMS sub modular symmetries
this this uh if you have attended
yesterday's talk by Catalin she's
already mentioned it so what is
um SMS what uh diff is different with
SMS from these others Dynamic systems
the idea is here that that's what we
send to our propagator is a partially
defined graph G and I think this is an
interesting comnatorial object which I
have not
seen studied somewhere else but it's
very natural because like when you're
working with we all used to work with
spatial assignments we always know for
our formula the sub solver of course not
only variables are assigned we have some
assigned to True some assigned to false
and there are some undis un uh decided
variables and now we use the same thing
now for a graph we have some matches we
know the edge is here some edges we know
they are absent but then there are some
undecided edges
and
um on this Edge variables that are
mentioned in this formula uh we um
usually when in the middle of dissolving
they will represent
um a partially defined graph
but now we send this partially defined
graphs to our check of canonicity
and
um now here because it's only a person
defined graph we need to figure out
whether we can extend this to a fully
defined graph because at the end we want
to have a fully defined graph that is
canonical
and if not we learn a clause
now this um Works basically like this
but how to do this exactly
um there it's not so straightforward
um here a little bit more on partially
defined graphs so here just we can
um
draw it this way that like this dotted
Edge is an edge where we don't know
whether it's there or not
um and also the adjacency Matrix is very
natural
um that we now have also a third symbol
we put a star at this places where we
don't know whether the edge exists or
not
um and
yeah and by the way this uh there's a
very natural partial order on on this
partially defined graphs where we can
say that one graph is smaller than the
other if so the larger one has basically
more edges decided that were undecided
on the smaller graph and so in this
ordering the minimal element is the
graph where everything is undecided and
the maximal elements are all the fully
defined graphs over the same graphic set
maybe right here
um X of G for the set of all fully
defined graphs
that g can be extended to
so for instance for this example here we
have like for every we have two to the
number of undecided edges
um many
um fully defined graphs
but so the ideal solution in our uh
method would be when we send this
partially defined graph to the
minimality check to find out to or to
recheck the current Branch if G is
non-can non-canonical in the sense that
none of these graphs
fully defined graphs she can't be
extended to is canonical so this would
be ideal
however when we
um or this is just an equivalent
statement for all age in X of G there is
a permutation by such that
um Pi of H is smaller than H so that
means
um H is not canonical right
I just write this here because we will
use a very similar statement on the next
slide
but this is extremely difficult to check
because
um there is an exponential number of
extensions of our partially defined
graph and for each extension checking
this minimality
um there's no algorithm known other in
the worst case you have basically to go
over all n factorial permutations
so we have kind of a problem that is has
two uh components that contribute to its
complexity
so therefore it's kind of hopeless to to
do this as it stands here
and even if we had it would be a
problematic because we can't have a
certificate if you later on want to give
a proof why let's say no counter example
exists and we use a lot of this kind of
of minimality checks then they can't be
represented directly by some kind of of
certificate
um but our solutions that we have a
slightly weaker form of canoni City for
partially defined graphs because
um in this weaker form we reject the
current branch of K which called
which we now call certified
non-canonical if there is a permutation
file such that uh bio of age is smaller
than H for all
um H uh all fully defined graphs G can
be extended to now if you look at this I
think uh wasn't that the same thing as
one slide earlier
no we switch the quantifiers so in the
channel I think we say for every age
there exists a pie but now we say there
is a buy such that for all age so it's a
weaker form because the same permutation
should now show the non-canoni city of
all the grass in XG
um and this is now
um the the the thing that we use
um you can so now it's weaker is it not
it's now not the full symmetry breaking
it's still similar breaking because
ultimately if G becomes a fully defined
graph for fully defined graphs these two
definitions are the same so uh sooner or
later we'll catch on uh and uh and
filter all um non-canonic programs
look and then once we have uh determined
that this is
um non-canonical then uh for our
partially defined graph it's now easy to
define a clause we just for all defined
edges with so we have a disjunction
which says at least one of the defined
edges
um should not be there or at least one
of the non-edges is there so we just
can't
have a negation on the partially defined
graph and this is the Clause
um that we learn
um because this for bits now all uh
graphs
even all graph G Prime that are larger
in this ordering
we can even do better we can even find a
smallest graph uh in this ordering that
is below G and for which Pi is still a
certificate so we can get a little bit
more even out of it because we want to
learn a clause that is as small as
possible
they call this this smallest graph
G by obstruction
okay now this is the picture we have now
we have here the partially defined graph
we fit into our check and our check of
canonicity our algorithmet we call mean
check uh for this we can show a certain
completeness
we can show that our minimality check
finds a certificate by this is this
permutation and such a cheap by
obstruction age if and only if G is
certified non-canonical so with respect
to our weakened form of canonicity our
algorithm is complete
yep
so so okay so I sort of went a bit
quickly so so what do you mean smallest
in the in the in the blocking course
um
in terms of this partial ordering that
we have on this partially defined Truss
so we can basically when we go in this
this ordering this Square shaped smaller
sign
we can from this tree that we send to
the propagator we might find an even
less defined graph
that is still an obstruction it's sort
of a listing of the of the working
process actually yeah there were some
things there are some uh edges that are
stable because the permutation either
fixes uh the The Edge or just swaps the
end points there are some things that
basically don't matter really and that
we can remove
I still didn't understand this point
so so I understand uh how you
determine that it's non-canonical the
the G the partial assignment uh but
you're saying saying that and therefore
you would generate a blocking clause
which would just block that partial
assignment correct
but you're saying something more
actually okay can you go back a couple
of slides
um
sorry to
[Music]
where you talked about minimizing
yeah
um
okay here it is yeah yeah it's just we
we find from this blocking Cloud Clause
we can in some cases find a subset
which uh is still a valid blocking class
how do you do that
I show it in a few slides oh
okay
um yeah I will go into this because this
this algorithm is quite quite Central so
I will spend a couple of minutes on on
it
um
and um and for this algorithm it's a
very fundamental concept here is uh what
we call an audit partition
so the one of our practitioners as you
would
um
guess you have a partition of the word
except into let's say we want to be our
equivalence classes but usually for a
partition you would have curly brackets
because for a partition it doesn't
matter
it doesn't order the equivalence classes
in some order but here we have this
linear ordering and such in order
partition represents a set of
permutations
for instance
um this ordered partition of uh the the
numbers one to three corresponds these
two permutations so basically
um we have like number one uh goes from
two or from three or we can swap uh the
other two but
um
one and two must be the the images of
the first part I set and and then for
the the second one only one is left or
if you can also uh just take this
general definition here
but this is now a compact way of of uh
representing a set of partitions
and our algorithm now works the
following way we start with the order
partition where everything is one big
equivalence class
and then let's say we stand vertices and
then we refine it refine it and we get
Singletons at the at a different the
number of signatures growth
and so to speak in our
um
in our uh
hsnc Matrix can also think of fixing uh
the the from starting from the left left
top Corner we fix more and more vertices
um and it's a branching algorithm so we
make some decision and then we might
backtrack uh and the important thing
here is the propagation
which I want to to uh illustrate with
this example so this is our adjacency
Matrix
um and here we start with this full
order partition
now maybe we make the first decision we
map one to one so we keep one fixed
which means now
um one becomes a Singleton
and the interesting thing and I think
there was the power of this algorithms
this mean check algorithm is now the
propagation because from this one
decision we get now a lot of other
decisions for free namely if we look
here at so we now know number one is
fixed
now we look at the other vertices
whether they are adjacent to one or not
now we for instance see that
um the vertices two to five are
non-adjacent to one
then six and seven we don't know and
eight to ten are adjacent so in our we
because we want to have something as
lexicographically minimal it's clear
that we have uh to
put now
does it non-adjacent vertices first so
two three four five come now in in the
next uh equivalence class
um the adjacent ones it might then come
at the last
and those that we don't know uh we we
can fix because
um
because uh they they can't be stable and
therefore
um kind of in adversary can always come
up with a way of this deciding this
edges uh so that
um that the ordering is uh not minimum
anymore so we have this propagation and
then we go on
um you know the next thing we will now
want to split this
that here so the first possible choice
would be to decide to snap to two to
becomes a Singleton and again here the
propagation uh would now say
um we have to split
um three four five first three because
it's not adjacent to two and then four
five because it's adjacent
um and something similar happens here at
the last step
okay and so forth and now let's assume
we are unsuccessful in this Branch let
me backtrack now here instead of
assigning two to two we assign two to
five
we have now to look at this row here
and again we do propagation and here it
turns out and I will show you in the
next slide wise we have a certifying
permutation fund because when we look
here
which any permutation now that is
represented by this ordered addition and
we if we now look at the permutation of
this partially defined graph
um we see that
up to this circuit place
um they are basically the same but now
get here we want and here is zero and
therefore we know that g is
lexicographically larger than Phi of G
and we have found our certified
permutation by
um and now the the the graph that we
know uh um the obstruction graph would
now cons consist of
um basically every Edge that is defined
in this block here
but we can omit
um we don't know they need to take
everything we can omit this uh stable
vertices
um
that that
um wherever any permutation would uh
basically keep this radishes stable
and we call this by the way an indicator
pair this particular uh like two six
these coordinates of this first uh um
cell where we get this this discrepancy
uh it's an indicator pair and we can now
translate this uh partially different
graph into a close
okay now
um yeah
we'll put that partition is similar to
the order partition pair that we have in
our Saucy symmetry detection are you
aware of that
no okay we can talk later okay
now I'm sure if other petitions will
have
some somewhere else it's a very
fundamental thing yeah University
performance University is also uh uh
this algorithm could uh need to might
need to consider all n factorial
permutations but in practice this worst
case is really net
um if but we can also monitor if the
minimality check is taking up a lot a
big fraction of the overall time then we
can also weekly and say only every case
time decision on energy level is done
only called the mean check then or they
limit the number of recursive calls
um
but we can still guarantee isomorphiness
if we run a mean check at the very end
of the process now the implementation we
implemented this in C sharp sorry C plus
plus
um
the environment for graphs directed
graphs metric hypergraphs and originally
the the hosting server was the class
ASB server it was at this stage very
nice to have something with a
well-developed interface that worked
quickly with the Prototype running
quickly and it served us for more than a
year now since recently this uh cardical
interface
talks yesterday about it with the
um
IPA syrup interface is now in some cases
quite faster so that's great now we give
give this gives the SMS framework also a
big boost
um
and we also have a python wrapper where
we can
quickly test some graph properties from
the command line
okay now
um for applications so we have quite a
number of applications and I'm trying to
show you here just a few ones where
maybe I don't need I can't spend 10
minutes introducing you to the
combinatorial context of the problem so
I
um I will be here a bit uh uh
superficial
um there is one of the first things that
we tried was the
regulated to the Simon multi conjecture
it's about uh diameter two critical
graphs so the diameter of a graph with
the longest distance between any two
vertices and the graph is a diameter D
critical if by deleting an edge makes
the diameter increase
and people in the combinatorics were
interested uh it was it goes back to the
1960s
um
to study the structure of diameter D
critical graphs and the salmon multi
conjecture
states that the number of edges in an N
vertex diameter two critical graph is
exactly a certain value which is
attained by a complete Piper that graph
and um
so um we could
um
I mean maybe I I assure you just a table
that maybe it's not getting too too
boring this is uh when we come when we
enumerate all uh diameter two critical
graphs
um and uh it this has been done with
multi
um
um not too long ago but with naughty you
know you can can enumerate all graphs
basically up to n vertices and then you
check whether it's uh diameter to
critical or not but now with
um with SMS we could enumerate all the
diameter two critical graphs up to 13
vertices
um here is maybe also it's a comparison
here this is would be the static mini
Melody check where we only swap two
vertices
um this uh um explained earlier
um and you also see that um at the
beginning okay it works quite well but
then there is a certain place where just
the number of graphs becomes too large
because it's not the complete filtering
and with SMS we can go further here in
parentheses you see also the percentage
of the time that's spent on the
minerality check
um but just for the conjecture we don't
need to enumerate all graphs we can just
give a bound on the number of edges and
and show unsatisfiability so basically
there is no no output no graph is put
out and there we can even go to 19
vertices
um
and
yeah here we also use some some landlers
that
um on the degrees of of the the graphs
um
yeah I to save time uh but but you see
there is quite some potential on on on
on their system
I think what's very important is that we
can also produce proofs
so even if you just
um
verify some results that have been
achieved personality now they can't
produce a proof
but here
um ours because our system is based on
cdcl
we can produce direct proofs and we can
uh like a an independent algorithm could
check whether our results occurred and
um also we have now the special Clauses
that we get from the minimality check
but because we have this minimality
check that uses this uh certif certified
non-canon City where we have this
permutation by our algorithms found so
we lock also this permutation file
and so for all for every for all of this
special edit Clauses we can also have a
very uh lightweight uh verifier that
after a successful run can verify that
every this certificate is indeed a
certificate and so we can basically use
a direct proof for the whole process
um where both uh
um the the reasoning of the solver but
also uh the the minimality this blocking
Clauses are verified
um
good
yeah I
I think I will skip the range set
because I want to use a few minutes on
planarity that's something that we
relatively recently added to the SMS
framework it's the
computation of planar brands
um so what what is when is the graph
planar a graph is planar when you can
draw it on on on uh on the plane without
Crossings
so this is the complete graph of three
vertices of course planar because also a
complete graph on forward vertices
explainer here it's just oh sorry that
was the wrong slide that's the better
one because I wanted to show you the
just by moving drawing it differently
you see this is planar however K5 as
long as you try you won't be able to
find the planar drawing of K5 so K5 is
not planar s uh also the piper type
graph on three plus three vertices also
not playing and actually these two
graphs K5 and k33 has some prominence
because they are the so-called
corradovsky graphs stainlessly
showed that a graph is non-planar if and
only if you can find the subdivision of
of one of these two graphs as a soft
graph and also the most efficient
planarity checks work by trying to find
such also called topological miners of
the graph and now we implemented this
um
in with another propagator so you can't
the non-existence of the suburbs you
can't encode these Clauses but we just
ask externally at the same time when we
call them the minimality check we also
call this external algorithm that looks
for this topological Miners and
if so we know that it's not planar it
can can
cut this Branch we also tried other
linearity criteria that are positive
that you can encode these Clauses but
the performance was quite I'll show you
a a table yeah this is now the process
we have the minimality check but also
the korodovsky
um
Criterium
and
um yeah here's something on planar uh to
run numbers uh we see here uh kovatorski
requirement the other one the ordering
Criterium which the static sat encoding
you you see that uh the kuretoski the
The Lazy kotovski encoding works works a
significantly better
sorry I didn't give you no detail what
are these planer to run numbers but uh
they are like in common hyperics in
interest people are interested in
studying those
and maybe just because it's such a nice
problem there was Moon problem uh was
formulated by bearing in 1959
because you all know a planar graph
famously can be colored with four colors
that's the Four Color theorem
and uh for color theorem was also the
first proof uh that was a computer
assistant proof assisted proof of a
major mathematical ethereum
coloring what is if every country on
Earth has a colony on the moon and now
we want to color the moon map with the
same colors as the earthmen so every
country on Earth gets on the moon the
colony Moon gets the same color how many
colors do you need
and
um
it's also some people said it's harder
than two
um Four Color theorems and
um it is only known that this number of
colors is between 9 and 12.
um and uh the lower point nine is due to
Sri Lanka who came up with this graph
which is a so-called pipeline graph you
can partition the edges into two sets
which gives you two planar graphs you
can think of this graph as a overlay of
two planar graphs and these are the
corresponding map colorings
I see I need to come to an end and here
we encoded this
um we needed to extend SMS to Digraph so
that we can put encode this
partition of the edges into let's say
red and blue edges by means of encoding
them in terms of a directed graph either
you have this Diagon or just a simple
Edge and we could now show that the
solanki graph is optimal in the number
of vertices
if we could exclude several other cases
um whereas colorings or chromatic
numbers uh that would uh contribute to
the last Moon program do not exist it's
also a general theorem
okay hypergraphs Matrix I keep just
quickly the summary
I think SMS provides
powerful framework for combinatory
problems it uses the power cdcl servers
generates direct proofs for verification
we have
applied it to many different
combinatorial objects and maybe last not
least maybe three uh
avenues for further exploration
can be improved minimality check maybe
because of this propagation may be a
constraint processing approach could
help and do a little bit more
propagation there
combining SMS with static symmetry
breaking which currently is not working
well then but we would like to get this
working internally because some of these
combinatorial problems you can't
formulate just with an existential
statement but it's more like a
qbf statement would be nice to extend
SMS to work also in the context of qbf
yes thank you thank you
I have an idea for how to make static
symmetry breaking work this came from a
student of mine just a couple weeks ago
because we tried symmetry breaking with
sat and for symmetry break static
symmetry breaking you have to assume
aesthetic ordering
of the assignments right and you create
a set of breaking predicates
and they may actually add Clauses that
are at odds with the branching heuristic
of the solvent
so he fixed the ordering in the
solver to be the exact static code the
same as the ones that used to create the
breaking predicates and his I said so it
didn't work he said it's better than
not doing it but so because you know the
static breaking requires a particular
ordering of the assignments
and then the sad solver goes and does
something different and so whatever you
add to the set to the solver becomes
kind of baggage that doesn't help with
breaking symmetries during search
so
but I'm not sure how this would be
consistent with the minimality check uh
that that's the problem because static
signature breaking of course it works
but the issue here is how can you work
it in conjunction uh with with this
Dynamic mini meditation
but the software is actually doing
search during that minimality check
right and it's branching basically based
on conflicts or you know something else
and it might choose the better The
Ordering of the branching to be
different from the Symmetry breaking
predicates that you may have added to
the software
and so if you force it to use the same
ordering above the variable of the uh
you know we can talk about that offline
yeah yeah but you know I don't
understand it but it's a great idea but
then when you added a cdcl solver it
doesn't work very well
let's have a final question there
so when you get so many outputs uh I I
don't know I never do that with a cdcl
salary because you find something with
10 000 outputs I have to add mine I have
to I have to you know I I mean I could
add another Clause saying don't give me
the other 9000 that I've already seen do
you does that actually work well I mean
for forgetting uh
problems with they have lots of lots of
answers I always I always use a
different sets of
yeah so so I think the question is about
the enumerate we calculate the the total
number of all uh grass with a certain
property yeah we do it this with
incremental solving when SMS outputs the
first graph
then we add another Clause that excludes
exactly this graph if we just run again
we can use the still reuse the learn all
the learn Clauses we can still use all
the Clauses that the minimally check has
has added and and and and and and and
built from there and this is then very
quick so first it might take longer to
get the first graph but then all the
others are usually found within a a
small time
uh
was that in order to get the results or
or to do the D right because because
often the d-rod takes a lot longer than
yeah the times I reported here on the
tables is without Direct
okay
thank you again
foreign